this great big story was made possible
by she'll make the future as an engineer
I'm always watching how things swim and
sort of thinking about them the goal is
to really be inspired by nature and take
this system that Nature has created and
understand the physics and then build
that capability into a new vehicle
[Music]
I'm Megan Leftwich associate professor
of mechanical engineering at the George
Washington University nice study sea
lion most animals swim with their tails
or their fluke or whatever's the back of
their body but sea lions use their four
flippers and clap them into their body
to generate a thrust that can propel
them through the water at incredible
speeds this form of swimming is found in
almost no other swimming animal if we
could understand how sea lions move we
could design vehicles that could one day
stealthily explore shipwrecks underwater
mines or unexplored caves
in 2013 I started to get serious about
studying sea lions and I put together a
team of students and other researchers
and keepers at the Smithsonian National
Zoo so I thought well we could use our
modern techniques and really get into
the nitty-gritty of the physics of how
these animals swim so we 3d print three
pieces with joints that represent the
elbow joint and the wrist joint and we
use different silicon gels to create a
soft robotic flipper and then what we're
able to do is use motors to actually
actuate that so we can recreate that
motion that we got from filming the
animals at the zoo directly from the
animals we then put that on to this
robotic platform to study not only how
the animals move but how the animals
move the water it's an understanding the
physics of that can allow us to then
build some of those capabilities into
the engineered vehicles that we have
it's important to take notes from nature
when inventing technology because Nature
has already done so much of the work for
us and so by looking around we can
definitely broaden our horizons and see
solutions that already exist we're
taking nature which seems to solve
problems so elegantly and being inspired
by those elegant solutions and you know
we often say like nature does that so
much better than us and then move on but
maybe if we say well how do they do it
we could start to increase our own
functionality
[Music]
you
[Music]